[Aplausos]
[Música]
hace casi 50 años en 1969 en aquel
momento presidente de eeuu richard nixon
anunció y puso en marcha la conocida
como guerra contra las drogas una
estrategia de mano dura que tenía como
objetivo perseguir y castigar la
producción la distribución y el consumo
de sustancias consideradas como drogas
prohibidas
el virus
desde entonces amigos a pesar de que
washington ha hecho uso de toda su
fuerza está estrategia de mano dura se
ha saldado con un estrepitoso fracaso
tanto dentro como fuera de casa fijaos
cada año el gobierno de eeuu gasta
decenas decenas de miles de millones de
dólares en esta particular guerra sin
conseguir prácticamente nada nada más
que encarcelar a cientos de miles de
personas y alimentar con ello la cultura
de la violencia y de las cifras del
gobierno federal sobre arrestos por
violar las leyes antinarcóticos ponen
los
pelos de punta
mi fa sol
fijaos cada año las autoridades de eeuu
detienen a más de un millón de personas
un millón de personas por quebrantar las
leyes antidrogas es decir dicho de otra
forma el 10 años eeuu detiene por
delitos relacionados con las drogas a
tanta gente como toda la población de
bolivia o cuba que se dice pronto
desde 1989 atentos porque el dato es
realmente sorprendente en eeuu han sido
encarceladas más personas por este tipo
de delitos que por todos los demás
crímenes violentos juntos ahora mal se
les preguntó deiss kokein en el trato
con la mitad y streiter
enero en google docs día de web de hecho
esto es precisamente lo que ha provocado
que este país tenga ojo la tasa de
encarcelamiento más alta del planeta
cuatro o cinco veces mayor que la de
países como francia o alemania y más
alta incluso que la de países
totalitarios como china de locos por
supuesto como os podéis imaginar las
cárceles de eeuu no son precisamente el
mejor sitio del mundo para rehabilitarse
de hecho la experiencia norteamericana
parece decir todo lo contrario las
cárceles estadounidenses son la mejor
academia para aprender a delinquir
[Música]
pero puede que estéis pensando vale
enrique puede que sea una estrategia
dura pero tal vez esté cumpliendo su
propósito verdad pues lo cierto es que
no más allá de abarrotar las cárceles
gastar cientos de miles de millones y
condenar la vida de muchísimos jóvenes
que tienen muy difícil reincorporarse a
la vida normal tras pagar muy caro sus
errores y esta guerra contra las drogas
ha conseguido muy poco prácticamente
nada de hecho a pesar de tantos
esfuerzos
eeuu sigue teniendo una de las mayores
tasas de consumo de drogas de todo el
mundo hoy esta tasa es incluso mayor que
en los años 80 y las muertes androids
identifac americans tuve dosis everyday
en milán smart struggling with eriksen y
respecto a sus resultados fuera de eeuu
que os voy a contar los que nos estáis
viendo desde latinoamérica estoy seguro
lo sabéis muy bien porque amigos una
cosa si ha conseguido esta guerra contra
las drogas
ser de oro a muchos narcotraficantes tal
cual como lo escucháis
[Música]
toda esta estrategia de prohibición y
mano dura contra las drogas ha hecho que
este negocio sea extremadamente
lucrativo casi una mina de oro y claro
ha enriquecido a narcos pandillas y
carteles al tiempo que ha sembrado la
violencia por toda américa latina
el cartel de la cocaína no comienza en
medellín-colombia comienza en las calles
de nueva york miami los ángeles y en
cada una de las ciudades estadounidenses
donde se vende y comprar crack
nancy reagan
en seguida flight pero un momento amigos
porque tras tantos fracasos hoy una
nueva estrategia está en marcha en eeuu
y de momento sus resultados parecen
prometedores habéis oído hablar de la
industria de la marihuana pues atentos
pues sixers
frei
[Música]
mejor
el gran cambio
y el pasado 1 de enero de 2018
california se convirtió en el octavo
territorio de eeuu en legalizar la
producción la distribución y el consumo
de marihuana para uso recreativo el uso
médico ya lo habían aprobado en 1996
además de california alaska colorado
massachusetts maine washington y nevada
son los otros estados donde junto a la
capital washington dc el uso recreativo
de la marihuana es perfectamente legal
por su parte el estado de vermont acaba
de anunciar que a partir del 1 de julio
la posesión y el consumo también serán
legales
ojo porque hablamos de un cambio muy
pero que muy importante sobre todo si
tenemos en cuenta que la legislación
federal como luego veremos lo sigue
considerando una actividad prohibida
pues bien el pasado año esta nueva
industria movió legalmente casi 7 mil
millones de dólares una cifra que se
espera subas con fuerza en los próximos
años sobre todo porque tan solo el
mercado de california se estima en más
de 5 mil millones
[Música]
hablamos amigos de toda una industria
que ya está generando muchísimos empleos
y que también está pagando muchos
impuestos y ojo no solo nos referimos a
la venta de marihuana para consumo
directo también están surgiendo un
montón de nuevos negocios que aprovechan
este ingrediente para producir todo tipo
de cosas nosotros vendemos dulces
galletas caramelos tenemos cientos de
productos es un negocio de muchísimos
dólares y el estado se queda con el 25
por ciento de cada dólar que facturamos
eric kim y dueño de feng west hollywood
como es fácil de entender los estados
que han legalizado esta industria la han
considerado un tanto especial así que
han fijado importantes regulaciones e
impuestos
y las ciudades y los condados han hecho
básicamente lo mismo la regulación
establece quién puede vender cómo y
dónde puede hacerlo o cuánto tiene que
pagar por ello es como cualquier otra
industria fuertemente regulada mira la
industria farmacéutica o la industria
del licor son industrias fuertemente
reguladas y la industria del cannabis no
es diferente para martín son directora
para asuntos federales de la asociación
de condados del estado de california y
no es algo precisamente barato en
algunas ciudades de california por
ejemplo la suma de todos los impuestos
puede llegar a suponer cerca del 40% de
la facturación de estas nuevas empresas
un 40% que se dice pronto por su parte
en colorado el primer estado que
legalizó la venta y el consumo de
marihuana para uso recreativo la
industria factura cada año cerca de mil
millones de dólares y los ingresos en
impuestos para el estado superan los 200
millones entre los 8 estados donde la
marihuana recreacional es legal
washington tiene la tasa de impuestos
más alta al red
del 50% colorado y nevada siguen con
tasas del 36% oregón tiene una tasa de
impuestos del 20 por ciento y alaska
tiene una tasa de hasta un 20
aaron smith reportero de la cnn sin
embargo amigos esperad un momento porque
aquí no termina todo digamos que hay un
problema un problema bastante serio
[Música]
y como os he dicho antes la ley federal
de eeuu sigue considerando que esto es
una actividad prohibida lo que hace que
este tipo de negocios tengan por ejemplo
muy difícil por no decir imposible
obtener créditos de entidades
financieras claro un banco que
financiarse a estas empresas podría
llegar a ser acusado incluso de
colaborar con el narcotráfico y no sólo
eso
y hasta ahora estaba en vigor una
política puesta en marcha por la
administración obama que digamos hacía
que el departamento de justicia le
pidiera a los fiscales federales que no
presentaran cargos cuando la producción
venta y consumo de droga fuese legal
conforme a las leyes de los estados pues
bien esta política conocida como el
memorando call han sido suspendida por
10 sessions el fiscal general nombrado
por donald trump
sandoval
smoke mail este fiscal amigos ha
anunciado que quiere perseguir los
negocios de marihuana algo que por
cierto tram prometió en campaña que no
iba a hacer
white take 6 en haití state y sus textos
así que ahora toda esta nueva industria
se encuentra cómo decirlo sumergida en
un mar de mucha incertidumbre cumplirá
el fiscal general sus deseos atacar a la
administración trump a la industria de
la marihuana estas son las preguntas que
están sobre la mesa y que sólo el futuro
nos podrá responder de momento amigos lo
que sí podemos hacer es fijarnos en por
qué ese cambio de planteamiento podría
ser un grave error
[Música]
un cambio de clave
han pasado ya unos cuantos años desde
que en 2014 colorado se convirtió en el
primer estado en legalizar el uso
recreativo de la marihuana como hemos
visto en este vídeo se han sumado unos
cuantos estados más desde entonces así
que ya podemos analizar qué ha ocurrido
qué consecuencias ha tenido esta nueva
política
veréis en aquel momento los críticos con
la legalización dijeron que los riesgos
de permitir el consumo recreativo del
cannabis eran muy altos por ejemplo
decían que probablemente crecería el
consumo entre los menores crecería la
delincuencia o se dispararían los
accidentes de tráfico pues bien ahora ya
podemos ver qué es lo que ha ocurrido y
lo cierto amigos es que los resultados
no han tenido nada que ver con esas
catastróficas predicciones no se ha
incrementado la violencia ni el consumo
entre menores ni tampoco los accidentes
de tráfico de hecho si algo ha tenido la
legalización han sido consecuencias
positivas
[Música]
por un lado ha mejorado la calidad del
producto que se vendía en el mercado
negro y también ha reducido en estos
estados el consumo de algunas sustancias
más peligrosas la legalización de la
marihuana para uso recreacional ha dado
a los consumidores estadounidenses
acceso a la marihuana de alta calidad
con cepas mejoradas genéticamente
cultivadas en invernaderos raúl benítez
manaut experto en guerra de drogas de la
universidad nacional autonoma de mexico
y ojo porque esto es muy importante hace
unos años el cato institute publicó un
estudio que determinaba atentos que 8 de
cada 10 muertes producidas por las
drogas se debían a la mala calidad del
producto esto es un problema social una
tragedia
vamos a ver el consumo salvo uso
medicinal nunca es bueno eso que quede
claro pero la demanda existe esa es la
realidad por lo que mejorar la calidad y
la seguridad del producto permite
reducir el daño causado pero aún hay más
la legalización también está reduciendo
como es lógico el negocio de los
carteles y por tanto el dinero que
reciben estos grupos mafiosos y además y
este es tal vez el efecto más importante
ha permitido que las detenciones
relacionadas con el tráfico de marihuana
se hayan claro desplomado lo que ha
tenido dos consecuencias muy claras por
un lado las fuerzas de seguridad y los
tribunales han podido destinar más
recursos a combatir crímenes graves por
otro lado ha reducido el número de
personas encarceladas por delitos como
el consumo que no afectaba a nadie tal
cual como lo escucháis podemos decir que
los estados que han apostado por la
legalización la cultura de la violencia
que ojo es un problema bastante grave en
este país se ha reducido y por si no
fuese suficiente encima la legalización
hace que esta actividad ahora pague
impuestos
así que amigos si eeuu quiere reducir
sus altísimas tasas de consumo es
probable que la legalización de la
marihuana sea una buena pero que muy
buena idea por un lado vierte luz sobre
un negocio hasta ahora muy opaco al
tiempo que permite que el producto gane
en seguridad y que existan más controles
además las autoridades pueden destinar
el dinero obtenido por los impuestos de
esta industria a realizar campañas de
concienciación y campañas sanitarias
algo que por cierto en portugal dio muy
buen resultado pero de eso hablaremos en
otro vídeo
el caso es que tal vez por todo esto las
encuestas nos muestran que más del 60
por ciento de los estadounidenses son
partidarios de la legalización
[Música]
[Aplausos]
al tiempo que cada vez son más los
estados que anuncian su intención de
legalizar la marihuana no solo para uso
médico sino también para uso recreativo
algo que por cierto empieza a ser ya una
tendencia
fijaos en 2013 y uruguay se convirtió en
el primer país del mundo en legalizar la
producción distribución y consumo de
marihuana aunque eso sí de una forma muy
regulada este año en 2018 todo apunta
que canadá va a seguir sus pasos al
menos esa es la promesa de su primer
ministro ya centro de turismo en
washington dólares
marwan der spiegel secrets esto es norma
que tenga que ser fuera ganando le
generen de china youtube ebay android
tener estudiantes que trajeran solo pago
contigo por cierto como curiosidad en
las bolsas de canadá cotizan unas 80
empresas relacionadas con el cannabis
pues bien en 2017 se revalorizaron ni
más ni menos que un 250 por ciento no
está mal verdad una industria nueva está
creciendo
una nueva industria en la que entre
otros el conocido inversor peter thiel
del que ya hemos hablado aquí en visual
político está apostando fuerte a través
de la sociedad canadiense private ear
holdings que por ejemplo está poniendo
en marcha en portugal la mayor
plantación de marihuana de toda europa
en fin amigos así están las cosas pero
ahora turno para ti eres partidario de
la legalización de la marihuana déjanos
tu respuesta en los comentarios y
también en esta encuesta si te ha
resultado interesante el vídeo dale a
like y no olvides suscribirte a visual
político un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]